je suis considéré comme un bien on prend
un avocat et on conteste
je suis samantha jackson et je peux vous
donner votre âge et m6 en bas j'ai pas
envie d'avoir l'avocat qui chante les
chansons de la reine des neiges à la
barre pour être reconnu en tant
qu'humain il faut apporter sa
contribution à la société
qu'est ce qui vous rend humain mettez
nous sur la voie what do you do les
cotes du tonnerre reviennent d'un
bonhomme de cette pièce vous auriez pu
être une source d'inspiration pour le
monde mais vous n'avez rien fait de
positif ça t'apprendra faire du sport
enfin je veux conduire 20 minutes plus
tard
sam table et 10 20 minutes tu prends le
relais